[Music]
a
tou
you
soid
sunlight eyes living
inside I can get over what
happened oh there Summer Don't Need You
[Music]
oh yes I'm fine
too no I don't need you
[Music]
you yes I'm fine to
you I feel some cing I just can hold it
back up on the rooftop balcony I can't
just relaxing
it's time better to even go I thought
never see her another here under my this
time not only
[Music]
remember what you're saying you can
feel I'm just taking I
know you're out and down fishing one
b and I'm living yeah me to
[Music]
oh yes I'm fight
to no I don't beat
you and still I'm
fighting I feel some cing I just can
hold it back and Up on the Roof the balc
my can't just
relax this time I'm about to even go I
thought never see
me under my book it's time not only
[Music]
I know
you about
me sometimes thinking about
you I know think again about
me sometimes think again you
w
[Music]
n